ever since I was a little kid
I wanted this
you don't know
my brother's sitting there he says thank
God we don't have to listen anymore
you can do it now my mom's home
everybody's watching
I have to thank the people at Paramount
I have to thank Jerry Zucker for taking
the time he took before he decided to
use me because it it meant he was sure
that it was for me
I had to thank Patrick Swayze who's a
stand-up guy and went to them and said I
want to do it with her I want to thank
to me
I want to thank everybody who makes
movies I Come From New York as a little
kid I lived in the projects and you're
the people I watched you're the people
wanted made me want to be
an actor I'm so proud to be here I'm
proud to be an actor and I'm going to
keep on acting and thank you so much
[Applause]